Um, do you take anything else that, uh,
is notable? Well, I can run you through
it. Sure. I'm on the lipid note.
A statin for costume. I've been
understanding since I was in my twenties.
Whoa. Yeah. Hmm. Uh, that
stuff's fucking terrible for you.
Right.
So my good friend and colleague George
Church at Harvard told me I'm killing
myself, but I have really
high cholesterol, my family
genetically. Genetically.
Yeah. And um, does your family have a
history of heart disease because of this?
Yeah. So my grandmother, um,
at least according to her had a stroke
in her thirties, and then yeah, it's,
it's bad. So I'm fighting
bad Ashkenazi Jew jeans here.
That's crazy. She'd been on
them since you're in your 20s,
that's in your thin man.
If anybody looked at you,
they would never think that you'd have
an issue. Yeah. It's unfortunate. Um,
but I'm a doctor's worst nightmare.
First of all. I teach them,
so I know what they're like. Uh, but
also when I go into the doctor's office,
I say, here's what we should be doing
or you should be doing to me. And I saw,
I went in my twenties and I said,
I want to go on a statin.
And this is in the days when statens
weren't well studied. And my doctor said,
but you're not old.
And I said,
I don't want to wait until I'm old and
sick to get this medicine. I need it now.
And I fought the doctor for the doctor
and eventually he prescribed it and my
cholesterol came down. Uh,
I'm the same with dentists.
I went to the dentist a few months
ago and I said, I want my teeth fixed,
my two front teeth. And she said, they
find normal wear and tear. And I said,
I don't care what's normal,
fixed my teeth.
Get them back to how I was when I was 20.
No, we don't do that. We don't do that.
Well, you did my daughter right
last week. Yeah, but she's young.
She's got a future like,
oh, little say hell done.
Don't be ages wrong with your teeth.
Although wearing out.
And I hated feeling that worn out. I'm
wearing now. You don't get that way.
Uh, just getting shorter and flatter.
And what the fuck you eating rocks? Yeah.
I must be the Australian Diet.
A lot of sand in your food.
Yeah. So I said to her,
I thought you were one of the world's
best dentists. And she said, okay fine,
I'll do it, but don't play
me if it doesn't work. Um,
and so she works well. She was worried
that it might snap off for now.
She's putting a cap on you. Yeah,
she's extending my two front teeth,
which is normal. Like people
get caps all the time. I,
well it's not a cap itself actually just
material stuck to the tip right there.
Just on the tip.
It's also like if you had a chip too,
they would do that instead
of replace the actual team.
That's what I did to my daughter. And I
said to that, to me, that looks great.
And she said, no, no, no. Finally she
said, okay, but it's your problem.
You got to pay for it. Fine. Uh,
and she did it and she actually said
at the end of it, this is great.
I might offer this as a
procedure to other patients, but,
but my point is not about teeth.
It's the medical profession is ages.
They give young people certain treatments
because they're young and they don't
give them to the old,
but then they don't give the young people
the treatments that they need before
they get old as wacky.
I had a similar thing happened
with a torn meniscus. I have a,
a minor meniscus tear and uh,
the guy told me,
well if you are young, they would stitch
it up and hope that it would heal.
I'm like, what the fuck does that
mean? I go, everything works good.
Like what is different? What is the
difference between me and a younger body?
They, and he said something
about blood flow, you have
more blood flow. And I said,
look, I'm not a doctor but that
doesn't make any sense. I go,
I'm working out all the time. There's
a lot of blood going through there.
Like what the fuck is happening?
And I'm like,
let's just shoot some stem cells
in there and see what's up.
Cause they wanted to do
um, meniscus. Uh, you know,
uh, what does admit menace
copy, whatever they call it,
when they cut some of the meniscus
out and I'm like, Eh, let's just,
let's just try, it's totally working.
Like A, I don't have any pain in it now.
So,
um,
I think there's a weird thing that they
do do when you get to a certain age,
you're like, Eh, like I have a friend
who was a torn ACL and they essentially,
he's in his fifties, late fifties, and
they essentially told him not to fix it.
I go, Hey fucker, get it fixed. What
are you crazy? And I have a wobbly knee.
And they're like, well, they told me
if I was younger, I fuck that doctor.
Go get that thing fixed. He's like, well,
how the recovery time, like shut up.
You just recover. You just, you're
alive. A year goes by, it's fixed.
Just stop. Just go get it fixed. Yeah.
See that's the problem with today's
society because we think a 50 year old is
Dale that's dead. That's
BS. 50 is still very young.
Actually there are 78 70 year old,
80 year olds.
Even nine year olds still playing
tennis loving life. That's,
that's just the beginning
of what's coming.
If you maintain activity that
that seems to be the key. The,
the really hard thing is when someone's
in their 50s and they want to get in
shape now and they haven't
been active their whole life,
that seems to be a problem. Their DVD
is scratched up. Yes. How'd you go back?
It can be done though.
I did see a guy who was 58 years old who
started running marathons at 58 in his
seventies he's running sub three
hour marathons and he looks great.
So it just,
he just had to take his time and really
be dedicated and watch his diet and
nutrition and next thing you know,
this guy's an elite marathon runner.
It is doable. What we find in the lab
is if we treat mice early in life,
it gives them the battle much
better life. Spanish. Sure.
So don't ever leave it too late.
Well you see that with
athletes like athletes that
were fit when they were young
and never lost it.
You really maintained and stayed
in the gym and stayed active.
You see them in their 50s and even
in their sixties looking great.
Whereas you know,
it's just once your body deteriorates,
it's very difficult to bring it back.
But if you maintain,
it seems like there's people today that
are doing that and it's much more common.
If you go to a gym, for
instance, go to a nice gym,
you'll see a lot of folks that are in
their sixties and seventies that are
really active and they're there all the
time and the regulars at the gym and
they look great. They do so much. My
father is a, is a prime example of that.
So he's in Australia and he's been taking
care of his body since he was in his
early forties. Probably a
little too late, but still, uh,
he's been taking some in a man and his
metformin for awhile, resveratrol. Um,
but he's been active. That's the key I
think. And then, uh, so that combination,
so he's now just turning 80 this year.
You would think that he's 30, if you,
if you didn't know his age and he's
running around and my mother passed away
from cancer, so he's, he's dating
women. He's out every night.
He's traveling the world now.
This is the future for,
for people in their eighties. Um,
he started a new career, uh, at 80.
Uh, it was at uh, 76. What's
he doing? He got bored, um,
till he retired at 67.
Thought he hadn't now the 10 years of
good life and he kept going and going,
going. His friends are getting
frail. He's still active.
So he went back and he's working at
Sydney University on the ethics panel for
clinical trials and other studies and
that's what you want older people with
wisdom and knowledge to do, to give
back. That sounds good too. Like for you,
you get your dad hopped up on
all these awesome new drugs.
Then you get them working on the ethics
panel for clinical studies and then you
get them to give you some death row
patients so you can try it on. Right.
Ethics, you're onto me. Yes, I
know what you're doing now, man.
You're wiggling the system a little
bit with your, keep it in the family.
Hyper active, super healthy dad. Right.
Well I don't recommend anything even to
my family, but they end up to manding it.
My brother was pretty upset that
we weren't giving him any. Well,
it seems like it's working out
really well for your father.
I mean seems Metformin,
the Nmm and a,
what else is he taking a,
he's also on a Staton uh,
and he exercises that's the main,
so he's understanding as well because he
has the same PR predisposed condition,
you know? Right. Yeah. That's an awful
condition, man. That that may mean.
One of the things that I was talking
to my doctor about was saying that,
that there are people that just have
high blood pressure or higher, you know,
higher blood pressure or higher instances
of heart disease in their family and
it's just a really unfortunate
genetic issue. Uh, it is,
it is. But fortunately we were able to
tackle heart disease pretty well. Yeah.
These days with blood pressure,
drugs, cholesterol, drugs.
There were some side
effects in a question,
but what we're talking about with these
longevity drugs that are in development
is that sure you can be prescribed this
medicine for your Alzheimer's or a few
or liver disease,
but as a side effect,
it'll keep the rest of
your body healthy as well,
protect you against cancer
and all these other things.
That's what's so radical
about what we're doing.